good evening I'm be happy Maria Gloria
and welcome to fuse
meme review Tiana Raynes I love your
honorees
sorry might fear the wedding is canceled
I'm saving myself for someone special a
stranger has just arrived
someone who's challenging the corporate
war
wayde's of samurai
a city to go
[Music]
but the big bed really stole everyone's
heart was the breathtaking Bay is really
going to be breathtaking this of course
led to many many many beautiful
beautiful memes Thank You Keanu with the
samurai we have to burn
Girish all right I don't know about that
one
Bart bartend okay
game game end okay lay it what's that
leg and my glove Keanu Reeves he's my
favorite actor
[Music]
okay let's see what grande did weights
of office samurai we have a city to burn
ah
[Music]
check this out oh my god how does
everyone be perfect green screen now
Jesus Christ eat well done oh hell yeah
the new undertale looks amazing wow I
can't believe Keanu Reeves is sponsored
by G fuel and he's wearing my cup
entered the code petabyte to bet it sold
out to scrubs you should have bought one
in time to minimalistic it glows in the
dark [ __ ] you lost your chance get us
check this out Keanu Reeves should host
ma'am review yeah dude you're
breathtaking Keanu Reeves river skirt he
always have the perfect response to
everything visiting not knowing why
everyone is using the Keanu Reeves
format finding out he says lonely su and
uploading all his memes
that's right everyone Keanu Reeves is
lonely someone do something god damn it
wait I'm lonely Keanu Reeves interview
has turned out to be fake Keanu Reeves
isn't lonely after all what but how am I
supposed to protect him how the media
portrays Puetz oh great
pears in real life you're breathtaking
yeah that's so great about Keanu he
always plays his badass but he's such as
soft wonderful guy that just likes to
smell the flowers or at least that's how
I like to perceive him when everyone is
talking about Keanu Reeves and you're
the first one to use the format from the
matrix no one's ever done this that's
why it's gonna work
I love the matrix it's my favorite film
being kind and loving being a bad egg
Keanu Reeves everyone that's exactly
what I mean but really what's making him
so likable like why Keanu what like
what's the big deal he has a backstory
okay promise you won't cry okay promise
you won't cry brawl it one of the
reasons Keanu Reeves is such a good
person is because how much he has lost
he lost his girlfriend
and his baby and he never wants anyone
to hurt the way he did even if it's just
with a good attitude he tries his best
to help others and bring them joy
letting fame go to your head staying
nice and humble you're breathtaking and
I can really relate to Keanu because I
am so nice and humble to check out a cop
beautiful
keyonna reason in movies / games Keanu
Reeves in person no one recognized him
Keanu Reeves waits 20 minutes in the
rain outside his own well that's gotta
be lonely if you enter your own party
and they don't recognize you see the
honorees is lonely goddamnit little
Keanu taking no chances look at that
dude
look at that dude look at that dude no
one will ever get Keanu Reeves whatever
allegation whatever thing you got on
Keanu no it's not gonna help him Keanu
Reeves demise will be his virtue he can
never be stopped and your fantasy can
never be quenched the day Keanu Reeves
get outed for a bad person is the day
the world is over because I don't want
to live in it anymore what is your
secret for always staying so
down-to-earth gravity ah you always have
the perfect response how does he do it
what do you think happens when we die
Keanu Reeves takes deep breath I know
that the ones who love us
well misses he has a perfect answer to
everything
Keanu Reeves is God I know it now you're
breathtaking wait that's a monster
change it now lush sucks or else there
will be consequences there will be no
more G fuel sent to your apartment
disappointed if calories was the pastor
of his own movie Church I'd go every
Sunday I love movies gosh I love movies
watching them
I love making them Keanu Reeves
appearing in a video game
nobody everyone I like you just add
nobody oh Sh
there's one space too many it's just I
just said nobody that's a nobody when I
realize it isn't the first time Keanu
Reeves is a meme rah
well it's almost like it's been a meme
like how many times Keanu Reeves
everyone the meme that will never die I
rate this
can out of can be oh wait it continues
sorry being in fortnight being in payday
2 was he really being in cyberpunk Punk
2077 see this one is way better Keanu
Reeves
I keep telling me he's God he's immortal
1530 1875 he doesn't aged at all 2077 he
still doesn't age how does he do it next
meme How to Train Your Dragon epicness a
new meme template it's much like for a
new meme template asking her for her cup
size okay that's a little naughty my
girl classmate my friend who told me cup
sizes were shoot oh I just got trolled
oh no that's awful
this one however is amazing whoever did
this well done very epic hot girl doing
her first song her parents me atreya
oh dude can there not be about
sexualizing ramen me making live
adaption of a meme so normies can't
understand it that's right normies if
you're watching I bet you're so confused
right now you must be completely lost
well then leave Doctor Strange sing like
singing the link ant-man to go up the
bus ant-man be like nunny with that god
damn it's so bad but still is so good me
doing my presentation about memes the
teacher the nerd was always on the
teachers side the boys me getting
suspended for beating someone who
bullied me mom my dad don't beat up
people resolve things with words okay
read this read it read it yeah that's
about this mean summarize for everyone a
sexy nude on the internet what is this
me realizing is my sister your friend
realizing is yes
goddammit so bad this meme gets a three
come on
I do like the face it is a funny face
for a dragon to make and I appreciate
that and also the finisher is really
good but come on is this the best you
can come up with an update update me and
the voice meme is finally dead everyone
we did it
congratulate the mold passed on it's too
old now it's been a week come on
seriously how long did you think it was
gonna light next meme we also have
Minecraft 3d edits I don't know how they
do out look around you but it's guys
damn I may say that this this didn't
exist before we are here look around at
the square I promise you right now we
did this doesn't matter what anybody
says
I'm so confused this bus has taken a
god-awful long time right it's so
perfectly done why is this a thing I'm
so confused but I'm also very intrigued
this your boy soulja boy knew by looking
at Campbell behind me though scratching
his neck turn up I got new shoes dirty
goodness why I don't understand
stop combining everything with Minecraft
okay
how and why Jesus Christ meme edits I
really picked up a lot there's gonna be
a whole generation of video effects
artists applying for their job so it
what exactly can you do check out this
minecraft Edit idea it's pretty tight my
god how did you scream it so well
alright look at these and edits like how
do they do it it's so good you always
want to look at the crust okay
you always gonna make sure the crust is
nice gold flaky and buttery if it's
burnt throw the [ __ ] out because you
know you a cross can either make or
break the pizza there's some people who
don't even need to cross but I'm gonna
agree with that you know I think you can
tell well done meme editors keep it up
proud of you this has been episode 5 a
meme review hope you guys enjoyed smash
like and subscribe it also we have new
colors out for the Sookie we have new
hat colors look at that dude look at
that dude
we got new colors for the turtlenecks
yeah you don't own a turtleneck what
I'll do is peel a two-bit simulator man
tester 800 cm do ilaria Oh sense us a
table body Takuro
turbo simulator if the new drop this oh
dude bro please
mana
[Music]